you know things aren't looking great for
Joe Biden when he's lost Adam Schiff one
of the most reliably partisan hacks in
the entire Democrat Party but that is
exactly what has happened when Adam
Schiff was forced to address Joe Biden's
classified document Scandal on TV
congressmanship you were on this show
just after attorney general Garland
appointed a special counsel in the case
of the Trump documents you said it was
the right move do you feel the same way
about this special counsel I do think
it's the right move the attorney general
has to make sure that not only is just
as evenly applied but the appearances of
Justice are also
satisfactory to the public and here I
don't think he had any choice but to
appoint a special counsel and I think
that special counsel will will do the
proper assessment I still would like to
see Congress do its own assessment of uh
and receive an assessment from the
intelligence community of whether there
was an exposure to others of these
documents whether it was harm to
National Security in the case of either
set of documents with either president
but yes I think the special counsel was
appropriately appointed uh Jonathan if I
could also though because my state is
still trying to dig out from these
terrible storms I want to thank the
president for making an emergency
declaration Nation I love that bit at
the end John I'd really love an
opportunity to compliment Joe Biden so
he doesn't totally hate me John I'd
really like to Curry a little bit of
favor with the guy that I just threw
under the bus so that I can hedge my
bets a little bit here but but still
shift through Biden under the bus he not
only supports the investigation into
Biden's documents he's even willing to
say that those documents might have
jeopardized National Security and Adam
Schiff has good reason to think that
they did jeopardize National Security
because it turns out that the Penn Biden
Center where some of the classified
documents were found
was reportedly funded to the tune of
tens of millions of dollars by Anonymous
Chinese communists
some questions come up did the donors
maybe get a tour of the facility
did those Anonymous Chinese donors maybe
get a peek at some of those documents I
don't know I'm not saying they did just
asking questions here why did the
Chinese fund the center at all why did
they keep their names hidden how are
they even allowed to keep their names
hidden when we know that age-old
political rule a rule that Joe Biden's
career has made especially clear that he
who pays the piper calls the tune I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from a video we put up over the
weekend this is the woke commercials ad
reacting to the the pro trans woke
commercials trying to guess which
products they're actually selling my
favorite comments from Robert Creighton
who says I'm trans these ads are so
inspirational and Powerful tears in my
eyes I identify as an American candy bar
my pronouns are her she
I lulled I lulled when I read it I can't
it's good I'm a sucker for a good pun
okay especially as our culture gets so
crazy I like I like laughing at the
culture and when things spin out of
control you're probably going to want a
reliable assets why you got to check out
Birch gold right now text Knowles do 98
98 98 the current administration's New
Year's goals are to tax spend and turn a
blind eye to inflation if this is at
odds with your goals and you're tired of
the government playing games with your
savings and your retirement plan then
you need to get in touch with the
experts at Birch gold today for over 5
000 years gold has withstood inflation
geopolitical turmoil and stock market
crashes now you can own gold in a tax
sheltered retirement account Birch gold
makes it easy to convert an IRA or 401K
into an IRA in Precious Metals text
Knowles kwels to 98 98 98 to claim your
free info kit on gold and then talk to
one of their precious metals Specialists
with an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to help
protect your savings text Knowles kwles
to 98 98 98 and protect yourself with
gold today how do you do it you text
Knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s to
98.98 98
the Penn Biden Center that's the fake
think tank that Joe Biden established
after he left the vice presidency
it seems to have taken a lot of money
from the Chinese we don't know what the
exact numbers are but here's what we
know
we know that between 2014 and 2019
uh Penn received
54.6 million dollars from the Chinese
that includes
23.1 million dollars in Anonymous gifts
starting in 2016. so right at the time
that Biden is leaving the vice
presidency
launching this big new center initiative
at Penn
most of the anonymous donations came
after the university announced that it
would create the Penn Biden Center for
diplomacy and Global engagement
kind of weird it's sort of like how
after the clintons left the White House
and they established the Clinton Global
initiative
with the understanding that the clintons
were still going to be very involved in
politics maybe Hillary would become the
president certainly she was going to run
for the president all of a sudden you
saw a ton of money pouring in from
foreign countries especially Ukraine
actually Ukraine I think was the largest
single nation a donor to the Clinton
Global initiative why is that do you
think they were doing it just out of the
goodness of Their Own Heart you think
they were doing that because they just
really supported
NAFTA or something I don't know some
part of the the Bill Clinton presidency
no they were currying favor with
politicians politicians who could
possibly help them in the future
do we think that the Chinese funded the
center just to I don't know promote
diplomacy and Global engagement or
because Joe Biden is such an admirable
figure no they were currying favor with
a potential player in the future Joe
Biden has wanted to be president since
he was a little kid and he intimated
that he was going to potentially run
again and so and even if he didn't the
bidens still play a big role in Democrat
politics and the Chinese especially are
known to do this they just place bets on
different people and they hope that one
of those bets pays off as apparently it
would have with as apparently it could
have with Biden and probably as it did
with Biden Trump was very tough on China
Biden the Democrats promised to be very
soft on China
Biden had been cheering on China's rise
for his whole political career Biden
said about 20 years ago he said you know
some people uh criticize our helping
China rise to prominence on the world
stage but we believe that a rising tide
lifts All Ships and that's why we're so
glad that China entered the World Trade
Organization that's why we're so glad
that China is now producing
so many of America's Goods that we've
shipped jobs overseas that we're now
super reliant on China that weren't that
China buys up all of our debt we're so
happy about that so so Biden was
obviously currying favor with the
Chinese as well the whole thing stinks
to high heaven and that is why
politicians even ones that are super
tightly aligned with Joe Biden are
trying to keep a little bit of distance
here even
the Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
do you believe that he's violated the
federal law here it's much too early to
tell there's special prosecutor in each
situation I think President Biden has
handled this correctly he's fully
cooperated uh with the prosecutors when
the documents were found he notified
archives it's total contrast to
president Trump who stole stonewalled
for a whole year but the point is we now
have special prosecutors on for both of
these situations very serious people we
should let it play out we don't have to
push them in any direction or try to
influence them that's all I'm going to
say let the special prosecutors do their
job do you support the fact that a
special counsel is overseeing this
matter now yes I do and in fact you know
I was this when when they first the FBI
went to Mar-A-Lago and they said well
what are you going to say about this I
said it's premature to comment and I've
said it here so I've been consistent
about it in both cases you have
prosecutors special prosecutors I
support both of them let them do their
job I think that's all that should be
said the politicians shouldn't be
buzzing around
the politicians shouldn't be buzzing
around giving their opinion this is the
first time
in Chuck Schumer's entire career that he
has has not wanted to buzz around giving
his opinion the old line was that the
most dangerous place in the state of New
York was the space between Chuck Schumer
and a TV camera and yet now he clams up
now he gets all reticent to talk about
it listen I don't
I think the president has done a great
job but I support the special counsel do
you think he violated the law well I
don't know it's too early to tell so
he's keeping a safe distance here even
as he's trying to Flack for Biden it
it's not persuasive
the the best he tried to do here to
defend Biden is he said what Biden's
done is totally right he's followed all
the procedures he should follow it's all
hunky dory
but if that's true then why is Chuck
Schumer happy that a special prosecutor
has been appointed if it's all fine and
Biden followed the letter of the law
perfectly and there's nothing to
criticize him for then why is he happy
that's being investigated by the special
counsel
doesn't quite add up what is Schumer
doing he's hedging his bets
he's saying look Biden is too weak now
for me to go out and completely defend
him
but he's not weak enough that he's
definitely done and I can pile on him
and completely ditch him so
he's straddling the fence as is ilhan
Omar
well one I'm glad that there is a
special prosecutor that's been appointed
to him because
time there is a deviance
in regards to security protocols that
should be taken serious it should be
investigated what I find interesting is
that Republicans who have defended Trump
after he literally stole classified
documents refused to turn them over lied
about having them made up some story
about how he Declassified them had to
have his how raided in order for those
documents to be found are now only
interested in investigating Biden who
has cooperated who his own staff and
former staff have themselves turned
these documents in so you have to
understand right Republicans aren't
really interested in upholding the law
in following security protocols what
they're interested in is playing a
political game just playing those
political games those those nasty
Republicans yeah is it a political game
in part it is
in part it's a political game of course
but it's
ilhan Omar and Chuck Schumer playing the
exact same political game and when all
the Democrats made a big hullabaloo
about Trump's documents which he had the
right to declassify that was much more
of a political game than what the
Republicans are doing now to Joe Biden
because when Joe Biden took these
documents out of the White House he did
not have the right to do that he did not
have the right to declassify those
documents Trump did that's a major
difference but of course they're playing
political games
and the the real political game that the
Democrats are playing is with themselves
so they're playing the game which is
they're going to straddle the fence and
do everything they can to leave
themselves an open if Biden does go down
they think it's serious enough that it
could hurt him but he's not totally weak
now the only person who is reliably
defending Joe Biden is Kareem
Jean-Pierre is his paid spokesman and
what's very telling about this
classified documents case is that the
way that the White House Press Secretary
is defending Joe Biden is by just not
talking about it she's just stonewalling
on the question so the Biden has no
defense here Trump had I think a
legitimate defense I mean I I'm very
persuaded by his defense some
Republicans are less persuaded by it
which is that he's president he can
declassify the documents in his in his
own head I think that's
totally convincing as far as I'm
concerned Biden doesn't have that and so
the best that the Democrats can do is
hedge and see-saw and keep their mouths
shut go mum and stop buzzing around even
someone like Chuck Schumer who hasn't
stopped speaking since the mid-1990s
now speaking of Joe Biden
Joe Biden
he makes some pretty weird claims
and he's not the most reliable guy and
he's been one of the most notorious
Liars in American politics since at
least the 1980s
and we got another doozy the other doozy
is that Joe Biden who tells us that he's
a devout Catholic and he campaigns on
being a devout Catholic actually grew up
in a black Protestant church
unless they want thing to rest I may be
a practicing Catholic we used to go to 7
30 Mass
every morning in high school and then on
College before I went to the black
church
not a joke Andy knows this not a joke I
went to the black church he made these
comments at Ebenezer Baptist Church in
Atlanta Georgia for Martin Luther King
day and Biden claims he says he went to
daily mass and then every day
he went to that to that black church
I assume he went with his friend corn
pop corn pop actually passed the
collection basket around uh Joe Biden he
wore big colorful hats you know come on
man listen here Jack that's the truth
listen you dog face pony soldier yeah I
grew up in a black church I was good
friends with Martin Luther King yeah you
know it no me and Frederick Douglass
yeah we used to go to the pool together
swim laps with Corn Pop he said I had
hairy legs come on Jack
come on man I don't I don't think
anybody who believes what what Biden is
saying but
the the most notable part of the story
to me
is that
any way you slice it Joe Biden reveals
himself as dishonest
because if he if he lied about going to
the black church all the time as a kid
which is probably the case then he's a
liar but even that first part when he
says listen I'm a practicing Catholic
what what non-catholics might not know
is that
Catholics are not permitted to
participate in the religious ceremonies
of other religions and and other
denominations
so if you're a practicing Catholic and
you go and you were you are regularly
attending a Protestant
church and participating in those
activities that's actually considered a
sin in the Catholic Church you're
supposed to confess that sin when you go
to confession you wouldn't you would not
really be able to call yourself with a
straight face a practicing Catholic if
you are regularly and willfully
violating that that uh requirement of
the church
but but of course going to a Protestant
Church would be the very least of Joe
Biden's infractions against his faith
Joe Biden is giddy about abortion he he
not only supports abortion which is
utterly impermissible for a Catholic
politician but he supports funding
abortion Joe Biden supports radically
redefining marriage this is not a
permissible thing to do if you're a
Catholic politician it supports all
sorts of things that run contrary to the
faith so I mentioned this not not really
to say anything about
Catholicism but to say something about
Joe Biden
any way you cut this story he's either a
he's a liar
he's not a practicing Catholic and he
probably didn't go to this church and
you can't believe a word that this guy
says and so when you get back to a
scandal like the classified document
Scandal this is why nobody believes his
excuses oh yeah Jack yeah they just we
forgot to take those documents yeah
that's too bad Jack that's why they
ended up there at the at the Penn Biden
Center well what about the documents in
your garage oh come on there fat don't
don't do me like that yeah it's next to
my Corvette it's cool it's all safe man
what about the other documents what
about this what about that he just
doesn't have any credibility at all this
is a man who's lied about his
professional career his beliefs his
accomplishments his involvement the
Civil Rights Movement that's another one
that keeps coming up he's like he's a
guy who lies about everything he'd lied
to you about what he had for breakfast
in the morning
and he he would even lie about a matter
as consequential as his faith
now
speaking of politics in the Catholic
church I have seen something that you
have not seen yet but you are going to
want to see it because it's very very
cool this is an interview that Ben did
our very own Ben Shapiro did with Frank
Pavone Frank Pavone a very very
well-known Catholic priest the head of
priests for Life who was recently
shockingly laissized by the Vatican and
another word for that is defrocked they
say you're no longer allowed to be a
priest and it's a kind of a complex
thing because the the sacrament of holy
orders makes an indelible mark on
someone's Soul so there's a question can
you even
really ultimately lay aside somebody oh
well the churches said we're taking away
your faculties to be a priest to to
confer sacraments to present yourself as
a priest uh for what for it's a little
unclear it's not no one has really seems
to know exactly why
so he just went on Ben Shapiro's Sunday
special and he made a really really
important point about his pro-life
advocacy
how do you make the case to people that
that would say that you know Catholic
Doctrine or religious Doctrine it allows
for a variety of opinions in terms of
how you vote so okay sure the Republican
party is for life sure the Republican
Party opposes same-sex marriage but the
Democratic party is more for social
justice matters it's more for economic
redistribution how do you privilege one
idea over another idea and how does that
mesh with Catholic Doctrine how can you
draw such a clear dividing line between
how people should vote shouldn't you
just sort of speak to Broad principles
and then whatever people do in the
privacy of the voting booth is what they
should is what they choose to do right
and you know based on the dictates of
conscience
the relationship between the issues
needs to be looked at nobody in the
pro-life Community says abortion is the
only issue what we say is that the right
to live is the foundation of every issue
if an issue is an issue in the first
place it's because it somehow impacts
human life why are we concerned about
poverty well people have a right to food
clothing and shelter why because they
have a right to live why am I concerned
about unemployment well people have a
right to make a living why because they
have a right to live protection from
terrorism you can go down the list and
it's like okay the value of life is
obviously at the core of every issue
such an important point
that conservatives don't make nearly as
much as we should
life is not merely one issue among many
life is the foundational right if we are
to have any rights at all we have to
have the right from Life on which all of
the other rights rely
Declaration of Independence says we have
rights to life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness life is obviously the most
important if any of those are rights
life has to be the most important
because you can't have Liberty without
life you can't pursue happiness if you
don't have life
and so when when someone like Joe Biden
comes out and he says well listen I you
know I'm practicing Catholic but I don't
I don't believe in the right to life
well you're saying okay I don't I don't
believe in any rights at all
I don't believe in the most basic right
of of all of them and so there's been
some speculation again we don't know why
papone was laosized I want to call him
father Pavone I guess I'm not supposed
to call him father Pavone anymore it
feels kind of weird to call him Mr
Pavone but but in any case he was he was
layicized some speculate because of his
pro-life advocacy and because he was
perhaps disobedient to his Bishops
and other people who may or may not have
told him to calm down with with all the
pro-life stuff again I don't know there
this has not been a transparent matter
but
what Pavone is saying is
I can't pipe down about this
this is a fundamental issue there was
there was one report that Pavone had
refused to to give Absolution to
unrepentant Democrats
and this was a big headline sounds
really shocking the sacrament of
confession is where Catholics go and
they confess their sins and the priest
deriving from Christ's conferring of the
right to loose and to bind Christ says
here is the power to forgive sins what
what sins you forgive are forgiven and
what sins you retain are retained and so
what pavon is saying is I'm I'm not
going to I cannot absolve someone of
their sins if they're not repentant and
the report was again I haven't heard him
say this but the report was that in some
cases he wouldn't give Absolution to
people who say vote for a Democrat vote
for some radically pro-abortion
politician and don't repent of that
well fair enough it seems to me if if
you're if you're sorry if you say look I
supported abortion in the past and that
was wrong and I'm sorry please I'm
asking God's forgiveness then you
receive God's forgiveness but if you
don't if you if you say yeah I support
baby killing politicians and and yeah I
think it's totally great to support
legal abortion and and even
taxpayer-funded abortion okay give me
absolution
pavon's saying I can't do that because
you're not you're not repentant a lot of
the opposition to Pavone is he's too
political he's getting too involved in
politics okay
I I don't even really know what that
means
yes we don't want to see priests you
know just chumming it up with one
candidate or some other candidate or
something we we want our priests to be
doing something different than our
politicians are doing sure okay I see
all of that but we're supposed to
pretend now that our our spiritual
leaders have to remain neutral there's
no neutrality we're in a spiritual war
and what we're supposed to pretend that
the guy who's running to save the babies
and the guy was running to kill the
babies that we're going to not have a
preference between those two things
we're not going to tell our flock who to
go to I'm not a priest I don't have a
flock but we're not priests are not
supposed to do that give me a break
that's completely insane it's a
historical it's completely incoherent
and I really hope it all works out with
with
uh
Pavone with Frank Pavone I hope it would
be it's a real shame to see what's
happened and it would be good to see him
brought back into the priesthood at some
future day I hope especially if they
only booted him out for uh for being too
pro-life it would be nice if they could
kind of work it out you know and have
him get back to his uh overall excellent
work
speaking of life and death
the story I meant to get to this a few
days ago
glad I got to announce kind of grisly
and really really stupid
a story here it is on daily wire man
Googled how to dispose of 115 pound
woman's body now his 115 pound wife is
missing
this is you almost want to laugh at the
headline except you realize someone's
been killed you know someone some guy
murdered his wife here it would seem and
and it's a guy from Massachusetts
who looked up how to dispose of this
particular kind of body and then uh his
his wife was supposed to take a ride
share to the airport in Boston for New
Year's Day there's no record she took
the ride share she never boarded the
plane and
then she was reported missing by her
workplace and her husband and then when
law enforcement searched the guy's
computer it says how do you how do you
dispose of a 115 pound woman's body not
really sad story not the brightest
criminal in the world it would seem I
guess he's innocent until proven guilty
but not looking good not looking good
for the husband
the reason I bring up the story is not
because it's of this local crime story
Odd as it is but it's because of what it
tells us about one of the biggest issues
in our politics which is the
surveillance State we are increasingly
living in a surveillance State and that
has been increasing for decades now it's
been increasing in the government sphere
you think of the NSA formerly known as
no such agency which is just processing
countless reams of all of our data
constantly but then you think of it in
the private sphere as well you think of
private companies that now have access
to what we search on the internet
private companies that have access to
who we call Private companies that have
access to cameras inside of our homes
it's just it's just everywhere now on
our TVs our TVs very often have cameras
our cars are spying on us to
corporations
so we're living in this this total
surveillance State and
our first reaction to that is that this
is very bad and it is bad because it's
giving bad people undue power
it's get it's giving frequently Very Bad
actors leverage over us and control over
our lives
there is a silver lining though you know
on this show I try to have a little
silver lining I don't really get angry
and pull my hair out and say the world
is ending all that much I I try to look
for the Hope here because I think that's
a a theological fact and a requirement
of our lives so here's the silver lining
the surveillance state
can keep you on the straight and narrow
it can people don't want to hear it but
it's true
if you knew I mean this is how a lot of
those
anti-porn apps work I think it was Matt
fradt really great podcaster was talking
about this that you get if you want to
quit porn if you have an addiction to
porn you get some of these apps and
services that basically whenever you
look at a porn website it just emails
whoever you tell it to email so it can
be a buddy it could be your wife it
could be you know and and so it's a it's
a voluntary kind of surveillance but if
you know voluntary or not if you know
that every single thing that you type
into your computer is going to be seen
by somebody else
you're probably not going to go to that
naughty website that you want to go to
now you you might if you're living in
China saying you know all your searches
are going to be seen by the government
you're also probably not going to Google
things like democracy or how to lead a
political revolution or things like that
but but even just in our personal lives
if we know that somebody is watching
we're probably going to be a little
better behaved
if you see a camera in a store you're
probably going to be a little loath to
rob that store unless you're in San
Francisco where it's just a complete
free-for-all if you are in in your home
even or in your workplace
surveillance can make you behave a
little bit better
the reason that this is happening now
is one there's been the technological
advances in surveillance but there's a
cultural reason too and it gets back to
one of these statements that John Adams
said in the early days of our country he
said a statement frequently quoted by
conservatives that the country is built
for a moral and religious people it's
not fit for the government of any other
kind of people that the American
expression of political Liberty and
relative privacy
is built for people who are going to
control themselves and rein in their
basist passions
the country is built for people who
believe that God is watching them at all
times and they better not step too far
out of line
as that belief has declined in the
United States
you you have seen an increase in other
kinds of surveillance
police surveillance in private
surveillance in surveillance by your
teachers and your professors and your
bosses and everybody else
as people don't fear God watching us we
are going to need big brother to watch
us is this something I've said
always as an addendum to the John Adams
quote about the moral and religious
people which is
there will be order
there there must be order and peace in
society that is that is what government
does is it to maintain that is what
political communities are largely for
if people will not order their own lives
someone is going to come in and order
our lives for us but there will don't
mistake it
the the people that control the country
the powers that be will not allow things
to spiral out of control even when those
powers are we the people even when it's
us in representative assemblies if our
government really were still to work as
the bill up on Capitol Hill and all the
rest of it
we would not allow anarchism you're
seeing this in some of the blue cities
where crime has gotten completely out of
control people are stepping up they're
saying we don't want this stuff anymore
okay impose some
control now speaking of big brother in
The Nanny State a story that seems a
little bit murky and the government is
trying to kind of deny this the consumer
product safety Commission
has threatened to take away your gas
stove
of all the problems facing the country
completely open border potential World
War breaking out in Eastern Europe
you've got uh biggest drug epidemic ever
in American history declining life
expectancy all of these problems the
government
is really focused on what matters which
is keeping you from from using a gas
stove to make your eggs in the morning
yeah you've got to use an electric stove
now that was the threat
from the consumer product safety
Commission
this came out people pushed back against
it even some Democrats came out Joe
manchin was interviewed about this he
said this is insane nobody wants to stop
trying to ban gas stoves you weirdos
that's fine so
then the government came and said no
we're not actually threatening to to
ban the gas stoves here is the consumer
product safety commissioner threatening
this just back in December I think we
need to be talking about regulating gas
stoves whether that's drastically
improving emissions or Banning gas
stoves entirely and I think we ought to
keep that possibility of a band in mind
as as you follow along because it's a
powerful tool in our toolbox and it's a
real possibility here
no thanks no thank you what how did this
guy
one if you if you cook at all you know
gas stoves are just much nicer to cook
on if you have the privilege of having a
gas stove I've had electric and I've had
gas at different gas is way way better
but how did this guy muster the gumption
to say uh yeah we're getting we're
taking your stove away yeah why because
I said so because I some petty
bureaucrat said so because we
have a culture now
where we have infantilized ourselves and
we've given up so much of our right and
our spines and in some cases other body
parts thanks to the transgender Movement
we we've given this away we no longer
have a clear vision of virtue and our
rights and our place in society we can't
even defend many people in this country
can't even defend the most basic right
in the society
and as we give those things away
then the people who are going to impose
the order that we previously would have
fearing God are going to be Petty
bureaucrats like the guy who's trying to
take your stove
despite the lackluster economy Maybe
because of it I don't know the daily
wire is thriving
and not only that we are hiring we are
looking for an experienced executive
producer and business manager who will
serve as the leader of daily wire's
South Florida branch in terms of both
production and general operations the
ideal candidate has at least eight years
of experience working in a professional
production environment in a senior
leadership position and you have to know
post-production for video and film
inside and out
in addition to technical proficiency
exceptional people leader skills and
business Acumen are crucial for success
in this role they also must thrive in a
fast-paced work environment and be a
self-starter this is an in-office
position in South Florida and a strong
preference will be given to local
candidates if this sounds like you then
head on over to dailywire.com careers
for more info and to apply that is
dailywire.com careers today
I am so happy
that at the daily wire now with all the
zillions of dollars that is coming
through this company as people flee the
woe corporations and they want to help
fight back and build our own culture and
we've got all this cool store making
movies and we're making products we have
finally acquired a piece of technology
from the 1970s or earlier that will
allow us to take live calls on this show
which I love because my favorite part of
the show is when I get to talk to you in
person so we've got some calls here set
up let's see who do we have
we've got uh Daisy from Chicago Daisy
you're on the air
hey Michael can you hear me I can hear
you how can I help you
wonderful so I've been listening to your
show for about a year now and I wanted
to press you on something
um you have alluded in the past that you
think people shouldn't be allowed to
cross-dress in public to me and I
suspect to pretty much everyone there's
a difference between a giant Burly dude
and a pink mini skirt and stilettos than
say a woman wearing a suit or even a man
wearing a woman's cardigan or women's
skinny jeans technically that all
qualifies with cross-dressing but
clearly it's not all as disruptive to
society so my question is do you really
think it should be illegal or just
discouraged and if you think it should
be illegal how would you define
cross-dressing how would that be
enforced really really good question
Daisy I think that in the case of skinny
jeans skinny jeans should be illegal not
for cross-dressing just because they're
a hideous offense against style but that
that's a question I guess for another
time uh you you make a great point which
is that the line line between
cross-dressing and avant-garde fashion
can be a little bit blurry I suppose
that's true nevertheless we can kind of
know it when we see it I think I go back
to Justice Potter Stewart who was asked
to Define obscenity we have laws still
in this country against obscenity we
have through our whole nation's history
and the the line between pornography and
art can be a little bit blurry in the in
the way that you're describing fashion
nevertheless Justice Stewart said I I
may not be able to give you a perfectly
precise description and definition of of
the difference
but we know it when we see it and I
think that's true so uh you know this
would involve a Prudential judgment call
on the on the part of the authorities
but so does all law enforcement you know
even the most Ardent positivist who
believes that the letter of the law is
exactly what should govern us it
wouldn't argue that there is no judgment
personal judgment that's involved in
handing that Court decisions and in
enforcing the law so we're going to have
that anyway that politics is a human
endeavor and so I I trust that as people
can distinguish between art and
obscenity in 99 of cases we probably
could in the case of cross-dressing and
and then I would err on the side of
caution obviously you want to err on the
side of of not being too overbearing but
but I think right now we're airing on
completely the other side we're we're
just throwing our standards and Norms
completely out the window and we're
pretending that there's some
constitutional right for a weirdo to
cross-dress and jiggle around for kids
at the library is your objection to this
idea of well of not of passing new
cross-dressing laws but really just
bringing back old ones I mean we had
laws against cross resting including in
San Francisco for a lot of our country's
history is your objection that it that
people have a right to cross stress you
know the stilettos and the feather bow
and all the rest of it or is your
objection uh that it's just as a
practical matter it would be too hard to
enforce
yeah it's not so much as um I think
people have a right it just seems like
if we try to bring in some sort of
cross-dressing laws it would be probably
too it wouldn't be practical
yeah fair enough I mean because because
your your objection at least is not
based on I think what a lot of people
mistakenly hold as this extreme
individualism that says we have the
right to do whatever we want or
something I mean that is nowhere found
in America's uh history or form of
government so your objection is really
just that you don't trust the government
to get this done because they're
basically incompetent and I I share I
think you're you're a suspicion of the
government uh however we do have to have
laws you know and so we we do the
government incompetent as it is we do
rely on the government to maintain order
and to execute Justice and and so in
this case a lot of the reason people
write it off is they say well it's sort
of a trivial issue who cares if some
weirdo wants to wear a mini skirt and
walk around New York City uh and and I'm
sympathetic to that argument it's just
my answer to it is who cares the libs
care you know the left has really really
been pushing this they put a lot of time
and energy and money into normalizing
this kind of stuff and I think they're
doing it because they recognize that
that cultural issues really do matter
you know it's not just fights over the
tax rate that that affect politics but
it's these these little cultural things
that if you're able to change the way
people dress the way people view men and
women the way people are educated the
way the way the culture talks about
about its own citizens if you're able to
change all of that in a kind of subtle
way then without passing a single law or
or only minor kind of regulations you
have ultimately changed the culture and
so I I'm skeptical of the government I
just think it's a it's a fight that we
have to engage in we got to go to war
with the army that we got really really
good question though Daisy thank you for
calling in okay let's turn now to Aaron
in the great Commonwealth of Virginia
hello Aaron
hi Michael
how can I help you
um so I just wanted to let you know I'm
also an Italian Catholic so I love
listening to your show but my question
is about working in the public school
system so I currently work at an
elementary school that's really
conservative and I'm lucky but I'm
finishing my degree in hopes of being a
middle school math teacher so I'm
wondering what advice you have for how
to work in the public school system and
not agree with or support their woke
agenda I would recommend that you be
wise as a serpent and innocent as a dove
and depending on where you are you know
if if you're in Virginia there's a good
shot that you're going to be in a pretty
pretty lib school system if you were in
Tennessee or Texas your odds of being in
a conservative school system would be a
lot higher I'm not necessarily
suggesting that you Retreat from that
fight but but I would recommend one
you know what you think
and you know what your lines are and you
know okay you'll maybe you'll keep your
mouth shut when in the teacher's break
room they're talking about how terrible
Trump is or whatever and you say okay
this is not not worth my time to pick
this fight but you are going to speak up
when they tell you you've got to refer
to one of your 12 year old male students
as she say that's a line I'm not going
to cross if I were a teacher that that
would be a line that I would not cross I
would I would not allow the school to
force me to lie and to lie about an
issue that is fundamental to human
nature and a lie that will really end up
damaging the the poorer students who are
who are being exposed to it so I know
what your lines are and then I would
recommend having a backup plan is the is
the other thing because you you know
that you're going into the lion's den
if you're working in a woke Public
School these days and I think it's
admirable that you're going in anyway
and I think education is obviously a
very important thing I remain close with
many of my teachers I in fact I keep up
with my kindergarten teacher you know so
I I think that's a wonderful thing and
you could be a real Lifeline for
conservatives and same people and
Sicilians and Catholics at the school so
so that's all wonderful but you ought to
have a backup plan because you're going
in knowing that you face greater risk to
your employment than the other people
who are who are going in there and so I
just you should go in with your eyes
wide open and not be caught unawares
when the libs try to you know tar and
feather you for saying that boys or boys
and girls or girls best of luck I I hope
you uh I hope you do wonderful things
and subvert all of the wokeness in in
whichever School you end up in okay
let's turn now to
Aussie art
it's an interesting name from Minnesota
am I pronouncing that correctly Aussie
hi I'm Michael no it's not it took my
husband three years too okay
how do I do it I see God
as he got asiat
yeah that's all right I'll keep trying
it might take me three years but that's
okay how can I help you yeah yeah so I'm
a huge fan I was like I can't believe
you picked up my call anyway so my
husband and I yeah and you always put my
uh stories on your stories when I tag
you on Instagram so thank you for that
too my pleasure my pleasure thanks for
tagging me this is I'm really glad I
picked up I'm certainly glad one of The
Producers picked up the phone uh so so
what's going on in Minnesota yeah
oh it's really cold and I really hate it
because I was born in southern Russia
and I hate cold and that's what my
question is about so my husband and I
are looking at moving from Minnesota to
Tennessee we are both young
entrepreneurs and when I hear your
thoughts about people and life and
Tennessee so what do you like the most
about living there asiat you you should
move yesterday you should not even wait
to until we finish this call you can
keep me on the line you can hang up now
if you want but just come to Tennessee
it is so great I just went back and
visited my old friends in LA because I I
still do a show out there with prageru
called the book club and so I go out a
few times a year and we film episodes of
the book club and I like it I go back I
see some of my friends most of my
friends have fled at this point but
there's still some there and I miss the
nice weather that's not something that
you will miss in Minnesota Minnesota
certainly does not have nice weather but
I mean I do miss certain things my
restaurant my cigar bar my this my that
but I am so happy that I made the move
because what what you get out of going
to a red state
is not only you get to save a lot of
money on taxes not only do you get more
normal people generally around you not
only do you frequently get a your dollar
going a lot further than they do in some
of these blue metropolises but you get
you get the standard back to a sane
place any place you move to you move to
Tennessee There's plenty of Libs in
Tennessee but the the center of gravity
there the political center of gravity is
not as nearly as far over to the left if
you're living in a place like California
the the dividing line between right and
left is do you trans the kids at four or
do you wait to trans the kids at seven
you know I mean that's that's how far
left it is I say this with almost no
exaggeration whereas in Tennessee even
the Democrats are still relatively
normal and that grounding in look we
don't want everyone to just believe
precisely exactly the same thing and to
just behave like automatons we we want
there to be diversity and spice to life
but you want it to be within normal
constraints you know Society is not not
a crazy jungle where everybody says and
does whatever they want and we're
basically all just barking at each other
we want Society to be a manicured Garden
okay and so when you move to a place
like Tennessee which I just adore the
the boundaries
of discourse and behavior are just more
than normal they're just people are just
way more normal here so I hope I've
convinced you as yet I hope to find you
you know at some restaurant in Tennessee
eating delicious fried chicken and
enjoying the good weather lovely to
speak to you I think I can take
one more question let's turn to Sam from
California from my old State hello Sam
hi Michael thanks for having me my
pleasure what's up
well uh I'm the CEO and founder of a new
Christian free speech social network
called Acts 29 or Acts 29 Dot online
and I'm an ex Facebook intelligence
analyst and the reason why I'm calling
is because we were recently
de-platformed from using our ad account
on Facebook
tell me more you've got my attention
well uh you know we started off uh not
you know we were always conservative but
we started off you know very light on
the political side but the moment we
started talking about our our country is
in grave Danger from the Communist
elements uh our ad accounts started
getting all wonky on us and they uh
declined our ad account seven times in
the last week
you know I'd heard that Facebook was
going to make a move to to suppress
political content and of course the
argument that Facebook made is we're
going to suppress political content
across the board usually when when
social media companies say that what
that really means is they're going to
suppress the conservatives and maybe
they'll give occasionally a little
little snack on the knuckles to
Democrats but but this is almost never
enforced equally and so I'm not not
terribly surprised you say you're an ex
Facebook intelligence analyst do you
have any
inside thoughts on on exactly why you're
being shut down
um I believe that it's because they
don't want a Christian free speech
social network you know a lot of the
employees uh at these tech companies
they double as
uh political activists and you see
political activism more and more in the
workplace and I believe in the last
three years you know it's kind of
converged into this amalgam of you know
communism within social either Socialism
or communism in the workplace right you
know it's funny to use those terms
because you know it's I almost feel bad
for the Communists calling these people
commies you know Stalin was a very evil
guy but at least he was kind of manly
you know at least he was he recognized
that men and women are different these
guys they want to take your property
they want to take your rights away and
but they're somehow even kookier they
some they somehow believe even more
Fantastical things uh so well I wish you
the best of luck I'm I'm not surprised
Facebook did show its Hand by saying
we're going to suppress political
content but the only way that we're
going to to do very much about this at
this point now that now that the big
tech companies have achieved critical
mass through fraud in many cases saying
that you'll you're signing up for one
service when in fact they're going to
provide you a different kind of a
service and and by exploiting legal
loopholes that give them protections
they've now got a critical mass and so
you're not going to succeed by just
going out there and building your own
Facebook we're going to succeed by
wielding the political order but the
really important Point here is that in a
political order in self-government in a
republic
if a private or semi-private entity
controls the Public Square they control
the whole political order and you and I
in America we still have rights to come
out there and and wield our political
power and say no we're not going to give
away the Public Square we're not going
to give away the country to woke wackos
in Silicon Valley thank you for calling
in that's our show I'm Michael Knowles
this the Michael null show we will see
you
next time
[Music]
[Music]